[Music]
hi my name is Anam and I'm data science
and I want to spend this five minute
steps planning the automatic data
annotation process that we are using so
I start with our general task and then
uh follow his distance supervision
itself
and the most pythonic part of how we use
a string search algorithm
so there are the main goal is a relation
extraction so we I want to extracting
from the rotech the information
of uh how uh the information that there
are two entities that connected uh
between some relation what do I mean
then example on the right then if we
have such Rotex it even marks a hugely
successful businessman who founded
Paypal we want to extract the
information that PayPal and Elon Musk
are connected with founded by relation
from technical point of view you want to
extract triples that subject of relation
object of relation and duration itself
so uh wire distance supervision we all
know that we need huge amount of data
for training our models and its
humanitated data is expensive so we want
to annotate data at a much claim uh the
distance supervision assumption uh you
see here it uh means that
um if we know from some sort of for
example from a knowledge base we know
that two entities are connected with
some relation we can assume that any
sentence that contains these two
entities uh might Express this relation
fortunately no but
let's stay with it uh here's an
illustration where on the left we have
the article from knowledge base Wiki
data and we can transfer the knowledge
to row text on the right to annotate the
sample so we can annotate that above
either is the employer of Disney and
held the position of CEO and do it
automatically and then we get the
training sample of the founded of the
employer and the partition Health
relations
uh one of the adventures or approach
that uh we need nearly nothing to start
we need subject object pairs that can be
instructed from some knowledge bases
uh and also we need the row text we can
annotate using this subject and object
from technical point of view it means
that we want to
find such pieces text that contains some
subject object pair of the relation
we're interested in
uh what is a challenge
okay it's in the middle okay
that actually we need to
search if one of hundred thousand
towards the cures in one of million
articles so take us
weeks to wait
um and fortunately uh all we need is
already implemented in Python we choose
the echocardial pattern searching I have
no time to explain how it works but you
can believe it's a uh first of all it's
fast and second is implementing C so and
then rapid python so it's really fast
so uh how we use it we from the subject
object pairs I speak before we prepare
the list of potential subject and list
of corresponding objects for each
subjects and then we have our search
text we run subject search
and get uh the list of text that
contains even one potential subject
and then we run object search
and got the
piece of text that contains subject
object Pairs and then we can use it as a
training data so uh it's really all and
what I want to illustrate that Python's
really isn't great for an LP task and
even it's not so fast you have uh you
can find everything all the implemented
and seen wrapped and python that you can
use Out of The Shadow Cloud as we do
with Echo Rising that's all
[Applause]
[Music]